hey i'm jared lewison and i play ben
gross hi i'm darren barnette and i play
paxton hall yoshida hello my name is
ramona young and i play eleanor wong
hello my name is lee rodriguez and i
play fabiola torres
hi my name is megan siri and i play
anissa qureshi hey
it's maitreya ramakrishnan and i play
davey and this is the cast and never
have i ever and we are going to be
reading some fan tweets
[Music]
never have i ever season two ah davey is
maybe as chaotic as ever you don't even
know
it's gonna be bad best male fictional
character of all time
ben gross never have i ever wow
[Music]
is living in season two in all of the
hot
steamy drama just waiting for you guys
to watch never have i ever season two
where'd baby ditches been and paxton and
dates anissa
martin denise against the gang
both fabiola and paxton and never have i
ever
on netflix okay okay
fabiola and paxton dating if she
i aspire to be as dramatic as eleanor
from never have i ever
we all do as we as we all should live
life as the main character that eleanor
wong is
never have i ever season 2 coming soon
and all i'll say is if i don't get my
ben and davey end game somebody is gonna
get sued
again that's a lot of pressure
legal action dude that's intense
we'll make note of that we'll make no i
wonder who you sue is that netflix is
that
is that us i don't know ben gross and
never have i ever he's
totally hot at af and i can't take my
eyes away from him
ah jaren lewison you deserve to be
recognized and appreciated with the
heart emoji
wow what i'm getting food
and that was wholesome not a day goes by
where i don't hear john mcenroe say
paxton hall yoshida
i can say the same and i'd like to
really make it my ringtone to be honest
i only care about one person and it's
fabiola and never have i ever and
you know i see it i've seen no lies i've
seen a lie
it's so cute no printer the new cast
member of never have i ever
megan siri you're so beautiful ma'am
oh where's the lie that's really nice
ari thank you
i mean look at those cheekbones man i
want
a spin off show of never have i ever
with eleanor
and her mom not gonna lie that'd be
entertaining
but that was
telling davey she looks good in her
story as he walks away smiling at her
does more for me than you think it does
you know what i can't even blame you i
would have loved that moment if that
happened to me in real life like damn
it's one of my favorite scenes i want to
marry ben gross from never have i ever
that man owns my heart damn first of all
too young to get married you guys are
15.
yeah that's that's true ben is been 16
now but still too young i think
oh right fabiola from never have i ever
is the honest to god love of my life
she has my heart and i would kill a man
for her
no questions asked please don't kill
anyone i appreciate it
we have lawsuits lawsuits and murder now
and murderers
that was unexpected the trailer for
never have i ever season two got dropped
literally yesterday and i already have
predictions for season three wow
predictions for season three okay
basically i think davey will choose
neither paxton or bed in season two
but in season three she moves back to
india and meets a boy there and it gets
all
messy
this is my face i'm not telling anything
i'm not i'm trying not to react because
i'm just okay i figured maybe both of
them will fly on a on a jet to india no
i'll
i'll swim i'll swim to india oh yeah
okay before i
swim there okay yeah you swim thank you
so much buzzfeed
make sure to catch never have i ever
season two on july 15th
only on netflix
[Music]
[Music]
you